In the Quran, Allah says, we don't. Can
I ask you a question, please? You don't
mind? You can ask me a question, my
brother. Are you Christian, Muslim,
believe in God? I'm agnostic. So, you
believe in the creator, but you don't
religion. So, we look at this creation.
You can see the creator's creation must
be wise, most wise, have wisdom. I don't
know, bro. I mean, like you can see
ourselves. Look, we have a nose next to
our mouth. Before you eat, smell food.
We have eyes. The water in our eyes and
the water of our ears. It's completely
different. I'm just here to see if
anyone wants to spit 16 bucks. No, we
won't. But it's what I'm talking about
is more important. Talking about go is
more important, brother, cuz any time we
can live this life. You know, when you
live this life, you're going to be by
yourself in the grave. Your mother love
you so much. Can you give me there's
another Before I give you proof, there's
another life. Before I give you another
proof, there's no but you're saying
before that, but I'm saying I'm saying
you're going to die. Answer my direct
question. Listen carefully. Answer my
direct. I'll give you proof by his
foundation. I can I can cuz the Quran I
can bounce around. I can I tell you I
can. I say I can. So then give me a
direct answer. Okay. Can you give me his
life after this one? Can you give me
direct proof? If you allow me to speak,
you're saying in the Quran that was
written something about direct. So the
Quran and the Bible and the prophets and
messages. You're about to turn around
the question. Can you give me direct?
Have you been to the Morocco? Yeah. Have
you been Algeria, bro? Listen. Show me a
exist. Show me a exist.
No, because you playing around. You're
not being
No, I'm showing you there's a way to
answer question to answer questions. No,
there's a way to answer questions. No,
while I was answering my question, you
should stop acting like that. You can't
answer. I can at all the proof how
people that never met each other.
How people never met each other and they
are known to be trustworthy, truthful,
telling us about the here after life.
How they never met each other. They come
with same teaching. Tell me how.
I like the I like the the noise of the
birds.
Can you tell me how have you got 16
bars? What about 20 bars?
I'll tell you better than the bars.
Allah said in the Quran the meaning of
the verse would they create by nothing
or did they create themselves or they
create the heavens and the earth surely
have no firm belief in this verse in the
Quran Allah gives us intellectual way.
This universe was created by doesn't
make any sense. Have you got 16 brother?
Take care of yourself. Have a good day.
That's the outcome.
Because I'm talking nonsense. You're
talking nonsense. You don't want to
listen to I asked you direct. Yeah, I'm
telling you. I told you I have bitter.
That's why you You haven't asked. I tell
you I have a bitter one. Take care of
yourself. You haven't answered any of my
question. May Allah guide you to truth.
Have a good night. Have a good evening.
Take care of yourself. Take care of
yourself. All right. Have a good time.
You too as well, brother. Take care of
yourself. Alhamdulillah.
Say something about this. He's too
drunk. I was no he's going to wake up
tomorrow even even if he came here. You
don't remember today. try to be polite.
You know, you try to be polite and nice,
you know, I speak respectfully. This
guy's going to wake up tomorrow even
remember he was
here to ask
you I live that lifestyle.
Alhamdulillah. And this it's not good in
a way but it's good in another way that
you know what they're going through cuz
I I live that lifestyle. You understand?
So it's not really good thing. It's
humiliation. You have no clue where
you're going. You just asking nonsense
question. You know you drugged. You know
you you're destroying yourself. May ask
her to guide him, you know. Subhan
Allah. And this is the true this what
the the establishment want you to do.
That's how they control you by occupying
you with alcohol and drugs and music and
turn you away from the god. This is what
is happening. And these the same people
who tell you against the the Babylonian
the Babylon against establishment when
it was when it is clearly been
manipulated and controlled by
establishments. You're drinking and
eating. You're drinking from it. poison
you get in the air from them directly
while you think you are free. That's why
one of our scholar said the slavery of
the mind is the worst type of slavery
where when you are enslaved mentally